la mia città
non esiste ma si può attraversare o da
abitare ogni volta si attraverso un
confine e lì sta lì finché tu non la
trovi o non incontri i suoi strani
abitanti sono un insieme di esuli
migranti esodati
viandanti senza tempo
signori fuori posto che si portano
addosso casa e memoria non certo il
luogo di partenza del quale hanno
soltanto brutti ricordi
io sono incazzato bianco
maggior ormai è il voto tra cuore e
cuore che fra la terra e le stelle
Eppure
i poeti i saggi i grandi maestri pittori
ma anche profeti che avevano lasciato in
eredità un messaggio di pace di amore di
umanità per prevenire la paura del
diverso da sé
ai mesi è poco amore In questo mondo
anzi vi sono sofferenze indiscibili
Milioni di bambini muoiono di fame non
hanno nessuna possibilità di crescere e
studiare vivere una vita vera e le cose
non sembrano molto migliorate fin dai
tempi di Abele e Caino soprattutto nel
sud del mondo
perché
pensate in Africa un tempo
avevamo sposato la natura dalla quale
traevamo tutti i mezzi di sussistenza e
di giovani crescevano all'ombra
dell'albero Baobab seduti in cerchio ad
ascoltare il nonno raccontar loro delle
storie e ogni storia che finiva si
concludeva con una morale e la raccolta
di tutte le morali diventava il codice
di comportamento che essi devono sapere
a memoria Ed è proprio grazie a quel
lavoro che facevano gli anziani non si
sentiva più di tanto la mancanza di una
scuola moderna si frequentava la scuola
della saggezza e anche per questo ancora
oggi si usa dire che un anziano che
muore sia una biblioteca che brucia
da noi in tempo in Africa
Ogni vittoria era comune e ogni
sconfitta era generale nessuno osava
farsi la doccia mentre il vicino di casa
moriva di sete il capitale in possesso
non si misurava mai in beni materiali ma
sempre su ciò che riporta la persona
alla sua importanza
al suo ruolo Quindi per noi avere non
era possedere ma essere consapevoli di
far parte di un gruppo di uomini sul
quale poter contare quindi l'individuo
aveva l'obbligo di tener conto degli
altri e considerava se stesso come una
perla la cui importanza aveva senso solo
considerando l'intera collana
ed era vietato pensare io ma molto
usuale pensare noi
il passaggio dall'adolescenza all'età
adulta non era automatico tutta una
generazione veniva affidata a un
personaggio in maschera che in Senegal
si chiama Cancun li porta nel bosco
sacro per circa sei mesi imparano a
riconoscere le piante imparano le
fondamenta della società
diventano maestri della parola grazie
alla facoltà di scegliere i termini
giusti per esplicitare un concetto
preciso Una volta usciti dal bosco
saranno riaccolti come uomini adulti e
maturi con il diritto alla parola
durante le sedute collettive
un antico popolo del Mali Considera la
vita in tre ambiti distinti da un lato
ci siamo noi qui presenti dall'altra
parte c'è l'universo dove vanno tutti i
morti e poi il pluriverso dove vanno
solo i defunti L'obiettivo della vita
era di raggiungere il puro Universo che
permette di essere Ricordati dai vivi
attraverso I rituali guidati dalle
maschere il tempo delle scoperte
l'evangelizzazione La colonizzazione la
schiavitù provocarono una cancellazione
repentina di quei valori morali
tradizionali gli africanisti passarono
di fianco alle maschere e Alle Statue
senza rendersi conto dei loro
significati
fosse
i giovani di oggi non si sentono a casa
in quel continente e l'Africa non li
riconosce più come figli propri la Terra
promessa è altrove oltre il deserto
oltre il mare
andare partire per forse mai arrivare o
forse
rientrare diversamente la memoria
incendia il confine degli esuli come
sale sulla carne Senza pelle
chiunque non conosciamo è semplicemente
un libro che aspetta di essere letto ma
da queste parti si è scelto di giudicare
il libro degli esuli soltanto nella
copertina senza nemmeno darci il tempo
di leggerne almeno due pagine
Io ho avuto modo di incontrarne tanti
con tante esperienze da condividere
diranno e uno di questi
la benzina era finita non c'era più
niente da mangiare né da bere Avevamo
sbagliato rotta tutto intorno a noi solo
l'azzurro del cielo e del Mare niente
altro avevamo sete erano passate ormai
tre giorni da quando avevamo finito le
scorte d'acqua ci siamo esfoliati tutti
uomini donne e bambini nudi e crudi come
Dio ti aveva fatti Abbiamo aspettato
mezzogiorno e mezzo quando il sole a
picco Abbiamo cominciato a leccarci a
vicenda perché così almeno mando nel mio
stomaco il sudore del compagno ma dopo
quei tre giorni eravamo talmente
disidratati che dalla nostra pelle non
riuscivo più il sudore usciva una specie
di olio e tutti hanno cominciato a
guardare il mare e gli ho detto ragazzi
Ragazzi il mare no piuttosto viviamo la
nostra pipì e tutti mi sono saltata
addosso sei scemo puoi fare a dirlo la
pipì non si può bere è piena di microbi
di schifezze invece il mare Si perché è
bello il cristallino e ovviamente non
vedi
hanno cominciato a bere l'acqua del mare
ma qui bevevano e più vomitavano Era
come se l'acqua fuoriuscisse da ogni
angolo del loro corpo hanno cominciato a
morire 3 al giorno
in fondo alla barca stava a una signora
con la sua bambina Maria si chiamava
avrà avuto due anni e mezzo al massimo 3
e la bambina piangeva piangeva di giorno
di notte Mattino pomeriggio sera come un
disco rotto io ad un certo punto mi sono
sentito orfano di quel suo disco signora
la bambina
ha risposto ma non capivo quello che
dicevo
Ma guardate bene Ho visto che giocasse
coi suoi cappelli giocavo con i suoi
capelli ogni tanto sussurrava qualcosa
alle sue orecchie sono andato a guardare
e lì
ho visto
la bambina era gonfia come un pallone
era morta ormai da più e più i giorni e
solo che la signora fosse accecata
dall'istinto materno non voleva rendersi
conto dell'evidenza se la coccolava
sussurrava
La bambina è morta dobbiamo buttarla
come tutti gli altri e lei mi sembra
tenevastemico ha strappate la bambina lo
buttate in acqua lei ha reagito si è
avvicinato sul bordo della barca
io ancora oggi Sento la sua voce così
flebile chiamare
si volta verso di me mi dice
li stavo facendo le treccine
io volevo che rimanesse bella anche dopo
la morte
le stavo facendo le treccine prima di
consegnartela Ma io non potevo saperlo a
quel punto lei si lascia andare e tutti
noi pensammo fosse meglio così
Il Pescatore che incrociamo mi lancia un
sacchetto con dei biscotti una
bottiglietta d'acqua e continuare a
ripetere come uno scaldabagno rotto Mi
dispiace
un povero Pescatore su uno tengo
famiglia
se vi tiro su mi sequestrino la barca
che penserà poi ai miei figli
Vorrei tanto
ma mi dispiace e non posso
Riavvia il motore e se ne va
Signore e signori ho maturato la
convinzione che oggi
urge condividere la ricerca di una
umanità che non si nasconde dietro il
velo dei localismi ma diventa evidente
ogni volta che noi faremo agli altri ciò
che vorremmo fosse fatto a noi e quando
avremo cura di non fare ad essi ciò che
non vorremmo fosse fatto a noi dare
cittadinanza al patrimonio culturale
altrui custodito nei nostri musei
renderli accessibile alla cittadinanza
coinvolgendo anche I migranti residenti
nei nostri territori forse ci potrebbe
aiutare perlomeno a discernere e poi
scegliere tra un immaginario collettivo
È una realtà vera
a tutti noi oggi tocca accogliere il
messaggio che tutte le culture presenti
nel nostro territorio contengono In
tutti i casi in cui sono coerentemente
volti verso il bene comune e non invece
come strumenti di esclusione ma questo
non significa rinunciare alla propria
cultura ma abbracciarli tutte cogliendo
da ciascuna di esse ciò che è ritenuto
positivo per migliorare se stessi è la
piccola porzione di mondo che ci
circonda
In effetti io io non so se questa mia
convinzione potrà diventare realtà
vita vera
Ma se ci dovessimo riuscire
Allora smetteremo di piangere per i
nostri morti
per incominciare a praticare ciò che ci
hanno lasciato ciò che ti hanno
insegnato ciò che ci hanno invitato a
sperare da vivi e nella società
tradizionale negroaf africana quando ci
si incontrava la mattina ci si augurava
buona morte
e io qui presente
unito a voi assieme a ciò che ci
riunisce Non posso fare a meno di
ricordare a ciascuno di voi che è
possibile morire senza mai cessare di
esistere
Arrivederci nel puro universo
[Applauso]